yeah why not go into the darkness
oh god
why are you doing this
get away from her
please i can't see [ __ ] by the way in
case you didn't know
huh did i come from there
i don't yeah to waste these
all right
crystal clear all right we're good
sorry whenever i'm so focused and scared
shitless i tend to forget to talk and
ramble or whatever
i am sorry about it but
i don't know
i just get so into it i
what am i guess to do here
the lighting is excellent i have to say
give them that look at this
it looks [ __ ] amazing
i just want to [ __ ] it
my [ __ ] i don't know why i keep
saying that someone's gonna think i'm
homosexual
free to think whatever [ __ ] you want
i i still don't know what my quest down
here is like what am i supposed to do
throw throw [ __ ] bread at his face
oh there's a girl here
no no no no no no no oh
oh [ __ ] that oh
did i scream for my mom